SAURABH GUPTA: So
welcome to NET303--
Livin' on the Edge.
I actually wanted to
have that song playing,
but twas not to be.
Just a quick reminder,
please do fill out the Dory
if you have questions.
That's how we will be
in taking questions.
Of course, there
are microphones here
if you want to have just
a live Q&A. It will really
help us record the questions
and see what kinds of interests
our folks have in the field.
And with that let's
go in to introductions
so my name is Saurabh Gupta.
I am a PM on Cloud CDN.
And with me here is esteemed
friend and colleague, Brian.
BRIAN ROGAN: I'm Brian Rogan.
I'm Senior director
at Google for CDN
and engineering for the
internet facing network as well
as interconnect.
So I think I'm going to
take it away from here
and walk you through our agenda.
We're going to talk a little bit
about the background of Google
CDN I'll take you through a
little bit about how it works
under the hood, and how we
think about the content delivery
problem at Google.
Saurabh is going to take
you through how to actually
get everything up
and running yourself.
And then we'll talk a
little bit about security
and how you can use
what we built to be
successful in your business.
So to start off, and I think
one of the things that TK talked
about a lot on Tuesday all
the way back at the beginning,
was about openness.
And Google Cloud
is about openness.
And CDN at Google
is no different.
Well, today we're going to talk
primarily about our first party
CDN offering.
We work with a series of amazing
CDN interconnect partners.
We can offer you preferential
pricing on cache flow,
so that at Google,
you know you're
going to have the CDN that
satisfies your needs best.
It's not about lock in, it's not
about pushing you towards us.
It's about the choice
that works for you.
Let's talk about where we see
Google CDN being different.
First off, I think it comes
down a lot to performance.
That's kind of our
headline, that's
what we've been working
on a lot of Google
over the last decade in CDN.
Is how do we have the
broadest reach, the deepest
connectivity, and
great performance.
And I think the numbers sort
of speak for themselves here,
both in terms of
throughput and latency.
So we think we really have a
best in class product on CDN
when you think about
performance and you
think about how to reach your
users all over the globe.
We think the products also
really marked by simplicity.
Saurabh I'll take you through
this in a lot more depth.
But you can turn on CDN at
Google with a single checkbox.
And with that checkbox, you
get all of our deployment.
You get you can reach all around
the world, and you get CDN,
you get caching.
And let's look at that reach.
So you we have 134
points of presence.
And again, for the
last north of a decade,
we've been investing in
our physical infrastructure
and in a network that's going
to get you around the world
and get you close to your users.
Again, we will dive
actually a fair bit
deeper into this,
and how we think
about this part of the problem.
But along with that,
you also get scale.
And you get the
infrastructure that Google
uses for its own
first party services.
And we have seven products
with over a billion users each
all around the world.
And again, we'll
dive a little bit
deeper on how we think about
that part of the problem.
So to jump in a
little bit and talk
about our network architecture.
I want to reflect
back on when we
started this journey at Google.
The year was 2006, we had
just acquired YouTube.
And at that time, if you could
make it through a YouTube video
without it rebuffering, it
was like a small miracle.
We kind of celebrate.
I ruined many a Friday
night social gathering
by trying to watch YouTube
with friends, you know,
popping out my TCP
dump, and grabbing
logs when things didn't work.
It was a super
awkward experience
for everyone involved.
I was not invited back.
But if you flash
forward a decade,
I think one of our
greatest accomplishments
is the fact that for the
vast majority of users
and for the vast majority
of workloads now,
connectivity blends into
the background, right?
I watch the Super Bowl on
YouTube TV five seconds
behind the [? MES ?] feed for
three hours without a rebuffer,
this year, right?
And as a user, I didn't even
think about Right I just
assumed that that would work.
And so I think what
we've seen over this time
is like an absolutely
transformative experience
in terms of what it means to be
on the receiving end of content
delivery.
And I think what that means
for you, for our customers,
is that all of a
sudden, you can build
all of these amazing experiences
where connectivity just
gets out of the way, right?
Where the users are not
distracted by the fact
that things are
buffering, they're
not distracted by waiting.
They can really engage
with your content,
and they can really kind of
work closely with your business.
So I wanted to talk a
little bit about how
we think about the
content delivery problem
and what got us here,
just to give you
some background about
what's underneath the hood
of that single checkbox.
So when we think about
how to reach the globe,
you know, step one is
kind of the obvious.
You need to go
where the users are.
And so the main challenge of
the content delivery problem
is kind of content
lives in data centers,
and users live
everywhere, right?
And so the goal is to figure
out how we can, with the best
performance possible, get your
content from our data centers
directly into the last mile,
and into your users' devices,
and into their homes.
And so first thing first,
we go where the internet is.
We work with anybody.
We connect to the vast
majority of networks
of last mile user facing
networks on the globe directly.
And that's a point
of pride of ours.
And it's a core part
of how we got here
and how we built what we have.
We run it at massive
scale at Google scale,
and so again, cloud
CDN product is
a product that leverages all of
the scale of the infrastructure
that we've built at Google.
And you kind of ride along
and you get that for free.
And finally, I'll talk
a little bit about this.
We've spent the last
few years figuring
out how can we innovate in
the content delivery problem.
How can we innovate in network?
And how can we make
it so that you really
have a very unique set
of capabilities here
that push forward
the whole internet.
Just to go back again, and
to talk about that kind
of content delivery problem.
You know kind of where
our data centers are.
You also have a sense
of in all of our edge
points of presence or places
where we have CDN caching.
And so I thought maybe it would
be kind of cool to take you
through a little bit
of that journey of how
your content starts
at a data center
and how it gets out
to the internet.
So I figured I would start with
this beautiful slide of one
of our data centers at sunrise.
And well, it is gorgeous,
and I would love to be there.
You will notice there are
not a great many users there.
And so that's sort of one
of the central challenges
out of that in general.
Data centers on the
internet are placed
in places where you can
acquire a couple hundred acres
and like, a gigawatt of power.
Not necessarily right in
the middle of city centers.
And I think this is an
important kind of insight
because if you think about how
the internet is provisioned,
how the internet works,
it's all around kind
of the centers of population.
It's all around the
places that you'd want
to go out on a Friday night--
the New Yorks, and Londons,
and Parises of the world.
And so there's quite
a journey to sometimes
be had from where your content
lives to where your users are.
So it starts at the
data centers, right?
But at Google-- and I think
compared to some other people--
content delivery is a
ground up problem for us.
And we literally think
about it as how do we
get from where
your content lives,
from where you're
workloads live, all the way
through to the internet.
And so here we
have some pictures
of some of the construction.
This is all first party stuff
that we've done a Google.
And up on the top left,
which I think is really cool,
is us burying duct bank.
And you'll see there there's
a whole bunch of conduits,
and they actually get strung
together in a metal frame
to make that cool square.
And then we didn't show the part
where they fill the whole thing
in with concrete.
Like, miles and miles
and miles of concrete.
So just think that
in this world,
this is an intensely
physical process.
That's one of the things I like
to kind of remark about in CDN,
is that for most
people, the internet is
this very ethereal thing.
It kind of lives
off in the cloud.
But in our world, I mean,
it is concrete, and conduit,
and pulling fiber.
And it is a very physical thing.
On the bottom right, you
have a little bit more
of an easier of long haul
pole with a little bit less
fiber, where we actually just
do kind of open trenching
that we cover in.
But again, these are the
kinds of physical investments
that power this
network that you see.
Obviously, we have a
significant subsea investments--
13 CDN investments that we've
done either through consortia
or with other folks.
And if you've never seen how
a submarine cable is laid,
it is one of the
most blowing things
that I have seen in my life.
I mean, we have a
gigantic cable ship
that literally runs cable
across the entire ocean,
lays it down on the ocean
floor through kind of valleys
and ridges, trying
to figure out how
we can make sure that
we have a clean path
underneath the ocean.
But the craziest part is
it's like not just passive.
All of this light
needs to be repeated
every 100 kilometers or so.
And so there's literally
active equipment
that lives underwater.
And when these things break
or when they need to be fixed,
we send UAVs down and
pull the cable up,
then cable tents for miles
because of trigonometry.
So these kind of just
absolutely amazing things
that happen under the hood.
All kind of sight unseen to
you the user of our service.
Then when we talk
about, OK, what
does it mean to like to meet
the internet where it is.
The internet is all
around the world.
And so this is actually what
maybe one of our 134 POPs
looks like.
And you'll notice compared
to the next slide,
everything here is
very clean and cabled.
But in the bottom
right, this is actually
what one of our
peer facing fabrics
looks like, just cabled up.
And the thing that you
have to keep in mind again
is just the scale.
These are sort of
two routers that
are part of the fabric
in one of 134 POPs.
And so this is just a massive,
massive globally distributed
infrastructure, with just
hundreds of thousands
of pairs of fiber, all of
them meticulously labeled,
you'll note.
Which I don't know how anyone
has the patience to do that,
but I thank them for it.
And so that's kind of what the
physical infrastructure looks
like on the ground.
And all of that is to
actually meet the internet.
And you'll notice now we're
kind of outside of space
that's controlled by Google.
But when you think about
how the internet actually
works in the real
world, it's literally
about two different
networks connecting
to one another physically.
And so we're actually creating
an optical path between say,
Google, and a network that can
help us deliver that content.
And it's sometimes
a messy business.
This is a Meet Me room at one
of our colocation facilities,
where basically
networks that connect
to user traffic and
Google will actually
meet up, make a fiber
path, and kind of link back
to our infrastructure.
So this is sort of
the messy business
of how the internet
works under the hood.
And I think just to talk
a little about-- this
is the result. Is
kind of what you
see with Google network tiers.
This is the premium network
that we keep talking about
and what it means.
Where you can actually ride
our first party infrastructure
right from your data center
all the way to the end user.
We also offer for more kind
of value minded customers
or for workloads that
don't necessarily
need the performance of that
premium tier, a standard tier
product which rides
over the internet,
and doesn't
necessarily get to take
advantage of all of that
privately built infrastructure.
But you can see the difference.
When we look at what does it
mean to be on that premium
network, in this
particular test,
we can actually see an almost
2x improvement in throughput.
And so those ground up
investments really matter.
And again, I think that's for
me the main takeaway here.
Is that when you
come to Google, you
have an infrastructure that's
built literally from the dirt
right up to give you
the best performance.
And you can see it.
I want to talk a
little bit about what
we were busy doing
on the software side
for that decade to get us there.
And here, we also I think, had
a lot of really interesting
innovations over that time.
One of the areas that
we've worked a lot in,
because there's such high
leverage, is area of transport.
So the protocols that
actually make sure we
can reliably deliver
traffic over the internet.
So QUIC is something we've
invested a lot of energy
in over time it originated
here, although it's
an open standard
used by many people.
And we worked a lot on how
do we get latency down.
And so we have the
zero RTT handshake
that allows you
to kind of quickly
establish a
connection to Google.
And you can see
what it meant to us.
When we flipped
on QUIC en masse,
we saw a significant improvement
in throughput across the board.
And so I think this
has been really one
of the key drivers of sort
of innovation of the protocol
level for us.
We also worked a lot
on congestion control,
and that was agnostic
to TCP and QUIC.
Both implement congestion
avoidance protocol
that we called BBR.
And that works on the insight
that whereas classic TCP
cubic for example,
will back off when
it notices loss in
the network, BBR
uses the insight that
in a modern network,
the routers have
very deep buffers.
And so you can actually
tell that things
are starting to get full by
noticing the packets space out
more and more.
And you can use that as
a signal that the network
is congested and back off.
And it turns out in the modern
internet for many use cases,
it's actually a much
more reliable signal
of the available
throughput on a link.
And so what we can actually see
here is that when we use BBR,
we can achieve significantly
higher throughput
in the presence of the
kind of sporadic loss
that happens on the internet
of over the same RTT.
And so those were
kind of two things
that I wanted to dive deeper on.
But again, I think it's
important to know at Google
that the innovation
in the network
is something that we have
been doing consistently
over the last decade.
A couple of things that are
particularly cool for CBN
are our Google global
cache deployments
that live all around the.
World
Espresso, which is our
internet facing software
defined networking stack.
And so if you can
imagine in real time,
one of the things that
we do is we figure out
exactly how traffic is going
to flow across that network
that Google operates,
and how it's going
to flow through the internet.
We try to make
sure that we never
overload any link we monitor
in real time, again, all
in software, every minute,
to see where there's
any degradations in
performance to certain parts
of the internet.
And how we can use
that broad footprint
to route traffic around it.
And so this also
I think has been
one of the key things, this
proprietary traffic management
system, that had enabled
us to really push the bar
and make things
better at Google.
So with that, I
wanted to hand it over
to see, OK, how this amazing
infrastructure works,
so we'd like to think.
And how do you actually
set it up and how
do you get all that simplicity.
SAURABH GUPTA: Thank you.
So set up and use.
How do you get started.
How do you make
this work for you.
So let's take a look at that.
First, we'll start
by seeing what
a traditional CDN looks like,
and how it thinks of the world.
You will start with--
there is actually a
gray box around here,
so use your imagination.
There is a gray box, which
is regional data center.
And in that, you have some
kind of virtual machine
or some kind of an
object store, which
is fronted by a load
balancer, which is then
fronted by a regional IP.
That regional IP is
advertised through
the regional public network.
And that's why if you have sort
of multi region deployments,
you will then have
that same deployment
across different data centers.
Each one will have
their own load balancer.
Each one will have their
own sort of regional IP.
And then they will plug into
the public network that is
proximal to that data center.
Which means you really need
to layer a wrapper of caching
around all this, right?
So you will then
have a separate layer
of caching that
exists at the edge.
Which means if a user,
let's say, in LA,
wants to connect
to your content,
if they're using
your domain name,
they will look up some
kind of DNS entry.
They will find the IP that
creates a path to your cache
endpoint.
And then also, the
caching infrastructure
will need to know where
to get that data from.
So at some level,
they will have to back
into the public network.
Again, go through
their public IP,
find the load
balancer et cetera,
and serve that content
back out the same path.
So really, there's lots of hops.
This is going through
the public network.
This is going to
a public network.
And also, at the edge,
you have a fair amount
of complexity in
configuration in terms of IP
based load balancing
or DNS based
load balancing, et cetera.
So this is kind
of like a summary.
Multiple DNS lookups.
CDN is a separate system from
your serving infrastructure.
Regional constructs with
again, regional IPs.
If you look at how
Google approached it,
we said, again, because we
have that global construct
to our VPCs, our load balancers
actually sit at the edge.
I mean, part of their
infrastructure is at the edge
itself.
And this is our Google Fiber
that Brian gave you a preview
on.
So when you have to
get data out of Google,
you have a global anycast
IP, so it's broadcast out
of all these end points, and
you can figure out the fastest
path to that end point.
You then ingress at
the edge location.
The load balancer
figures out how
to route the traffic
efficiently through the backbone
to where the data
is actually stored.
You traverse this
private fiber path.
Again, also, to the private.
You traverse this
private fiber path
to the correct data center.
You get your data, and you
then traverse that back out.
So what you get are distributed
constructs all the way through,
right?
You get distributed load
balancing, distributed caching,
and distributed SSL at the edge.
There is another cool
thing that happens here.
So the SSL will
be advertised out
at this end point, so
the your front end will
have your domain based SSL.
And let's say you
say, you know what,
I want this to simply serve HTTP
to my load balancer front end.
That will still be an
encrypted transit path.
Google is just going to
encrypt that in transit,
so you don't have
to explicitly create
an SSL infrastructure to have
this edge traffic reach here.
You obviously can.
You can have self
signed keys, you
can have all those
types of things.
But in general, by
putting SSL at the edge,
you start to get all the
benefits of QUIC and HTTP/2,
the fast handshake
negotiation, et cetera.
And you get a fairly
secured [INAUDIBLE]..
You get a secure pipe all
the way through to where
your data is stored.
So let's actually see
how some of this works.
So here, I have an origin,
which is a bucket of data.
Can we switch to the demo?
And here's the bucket.
So the bucket is public.
It's called public as
a data in it is public.
But the bucket
itself is private.
You cannot list it
or sort of browse it.
And here, we have all
the different objects
that we will be serving.
So these are all
MPEG Dash chunks.
And here you can see
sort of the metadata
for it, where at
the object level,
I'm setting up
the cache control.
So there, I've said
this is public.
And the TTL is about 20 minutes.
So here you've seen the bucket.
You've seen the chunks.
And you saw how we set the
metadata at the object level
to market public with
a certain cache value.
So now, let's actually
set up this infrastructure
and see what it looks like.
So we'll be going back
and forth between the demo
and the slides for a bit.
So let's create the any
cast IP that you just saw.
So if I go to my VPC networks--
and again, I'll
just take one moment
to highlight what this
looks like in real life when
you log into the console.
You will see here it's one
VPC, that's my default VPC,
but it's got IP addresses
in every single region.
Which means if I need to send
traffic from here to there,
I don't really need to do
any kind of transit link.
I just go from one 10.
address to another 10.
address, and it just traverses.
So that's sort of the whole
global network and premium
network and all those constructs
that we were talking about.
So let's go ahead and
create one of those fancy IP
addresses we were talking about.
Reserve static IP address.
And let's call this
the Demo CDN IP.
We want the premium
network, IPv4, that's fine.
And we want a global ID.
So let's go ahead
and click Reserve.
It's going to take a few
seconds while it spins.
And it's going to give us
after that an IP address
that we can use.
Can we switch to slides?
Thanks.
So we did we did that part.
We figured out a way that
a end client can look up
an IP address and get to us.
But we didn't
create a DNS entry.
So let's do that next.
So here are IP
addresses created.
I have the address.
Let's copy that.
Let's go to our network
services, Cloud DNS.
And I have a CDN zone
where on a certain domain,
I've sort of directed
the name servers here.
So I'll add a record set.
And I'm going to give
it, let's say, demo.
And I'm going to put in the
anycast IP that we had captured
and we hit Create.
So here I now have a DNS
entry that maps to that IP
address that we just created.
So our front end is
kind of sort of done.
Now let's create
the load balancer.
So the load balancer is going
to do a couple of things.
It's going to say,
here's my front end.
I want you to serve
out of this IP address.
And we need to attach the SSL
that represents that domain
name that we just created.
So let's do that.
So here's in network services,
here's my load balancer.
Click.
And let's create
a load balancer.
And of course, this is
going to be an HTTPS load
balancer, so let's click that.
Select start configuration.
And we were going
to do the front end.
So here, let's call it demo
CDN load balancer front end.
We want HTTPS.
And it's going to
be using premium.
And we created this
IP address, so it's
going to let us select that.
443.
Now we need to attach
the certificate.
Where's that going to come from?
So let's create a new one.
So let's call it demo
CDN lb SSL certificate.
And here I can actually
just select Google managed.
So I really don't have to figure
out what was that open SSL
command, or how do
I create my CSR,
and where do I send it,
and those types of things.
And it makes it really easy
to get an SSL up and running.
And so here's a managed SSL.
I hit Create.
And that starts to create
the certificate that
will then get attached to
my front end load balancer.
So here, I'm saying the
SSL policy's defaults
and QUIC negotiation
is automatic.
So without really doing
a lot, the front end
will automatically
to try to detect
how advanced your
client is, and if it
can support some of these
more advanced protocols.
And it will negotiate
the fastest way
to get a handshake going
and establish a connection.
So that's done.
Let me switch.
So so far, we created
the front end,
and we attached the SSL to it.
Now what we have to do
is create the back end.
So once the traffic arrives on
that IP, and SSL is negotiated,
et cetera, the traffic has to
go somewhere to get the data.
Where does it go?
We've created that bucket.
And so we're going to make
that bucket a back end
service that the load balancer
will direct traffic to.
And the back, it could be
a bucket, it could be a VM,
you don't really have to--
I mean, you can
choose either one.
In this, we're just
using a bucket,
so that makes it simpler.
So switch to the demo.
So here in that
same load balancer--
let me actually give it a name.
Demo CDN lb 1.
So here's my back end.
And I don't have any
services attached.
So let's create a back end
bucket, which is specifically
a serving bucket.
Now let's do demo
CDN back end bucket.
And select the bucket that
we want, which is this one.
Select.
And again, if you recall, we
had shown that simplicity, which
is that checkbox right there.
So once we click
that, it will actually
activate caching at the edge
when this service becomes
live on the load balancer.
That's it.
Create.
So switch to the slides.
Great.
So we've stepped
through that part.
We stepped through that part,
we stepped through that part.
Back end mapping to a bucket.
And we actually
activated caching.
So we just have one other thing
to do is to save the URL map.
The map is already done for us.
It's a default map.
It is to say if I
get an HTTP path,
where does it go, how
do I send it somewhere.
So there's already
a default route.
If we switch, we can show
what that looks like.
So here in our host
path rules, you
can see there's a default path
that says anything unmatched.
We'll go to this demo
bucket that we just
created as a back end.
So review and finalize.
That's kind of
what it looks like.
And we hit to create.
So now this load balancer
is getting created.
What's happening at as
we speak in this process,
if we switch to the slides.
Let's go back one.
What's happening now is that the
IP is getting propagated out.
So this configuration
is getting stood up,
the SSL certificates are being
replicated across the globe
for serving at the
edge, no matter where
the traffic comes in.
And the configuration
to map that back end
service to this bucket is
also getting pushed out.
So really, right now, while
that thing is spinning,
we are getting a
full edge deployment.
In our setup, we did a
bunch of steps, anycast DNS,
load balancer
front end to a SSL,
load balance at the
back end to a CDN.
And a URL map to
the content bucket.
So now, let's see what
it actually looks like.
So while it's
getting pushed out--
I'm of the Julia Child
school of technical demos--
while the turkey
is in the oven, we
have a fully baked
one for you, which
looks a little bit like this.
So this is a load balancer
I had created earlier.
This has already
been pushed out,
and everything is deployed.
So if you see what that
looks like, this is here.
So here, you have
a custom subdomain
on this content, which
is getting served out.
If you see with
what this maps to,
this web slash index of HTML.
If you go here in the bucket,
you have a web folder,
and it's just a static
website, this index of HTML
that's getting served out.
So that's what you're seeing.
So if we go back, you see that.
And I'm going to
start a video, which
is getting served out of CDN.
So I hit click.
So this is MPEG dash.
And let's see if I
can make it smaller.
So here as the video
is playing, you
will see I'm using the
browser performance
API to capture the duration that
it takes for the HTTP request
to complete.
Here, you can see
the MP4 files that we
are retrieving for the
two second segment length.
And you can see the data size.
So as the video plays, you
have between 100 to 200
milliseconds round trip of
retrieval for the full content.
So let's then click that again.
And here, you see now, because
the content is already cached,
and if I play it, you can see
here the duration has gone down
to between 0 and
10 milliseconds.
And you'll see the
difference as soon
as it hits the point where we
stop the video and rewound it.
The caching will
continue, but again, it's
a two second segment that the
system has not seen before.
But it's able to
deliver it in a manner
that you really
don't have any drops.
I actually ran this test from
an airplane on airplane Wi-Fi,
and I still got pretty
much the same results
between the 100 to 200
milliseconds average.
So that was pretty good.
I don't know if you've
seen this video.
This is one of the
April Fools videos
we put out a couple
of years ago.
It's about self-driving bikes.
It's very cool.
Great.
So can we switch to the slides?
All right.
So we take a look.
So let's also visualize
the network path,
what that actually looks like.
Because Brian
talked a little bit
about the premium network,
and the standard network,
and the path things take.
So I will actually
want to show you
what you just saw, what the
network path or something
like that would be.
So if we can switch
to the demo again.
Here's sort of the exploration
of Google's network.
So let's begin.
And it's telling us about
standard versus regular.
So let's take a look at
what public looks like.
If our origin is
in Oregon, and we
want to be somewhere
out here, and we hit go,
traffic will egress from Oregon.
It'll bounce around.
It goes and takes a
nice lazily stroll
through Canada, and finally
lands where you actually
want to see content.
And when you're traversing
the standard network
or any other sort of generic
cloud provider network,
this is sort of what you get.
Which means if you're CDN is
like that, that's kind of what
you're going to get, too.
In fact, the reason
CDNs were built
was because this was happening.
That's why you needed something
very close to actually send
that traffic to this person,
which then also meant
that you have constructs such
as prewarming, precaching,
et cetera, et cetera.
But when you switch to
the premium network,
a lot of those constructs
really start to get redefined.
Because what happens is you
do take that direct path
to the closest POP, and
then you have a very short
public transit path.
And milliseconds count, right?
If you look at the
speed of light,
each millisecond is about
186 miles of transit.
So if you're shaving
milliseconds off
in this transit, it
allows that single POP
to serve a much wider radius.
So when you do that sort of
optimal curve math and all
that, you start to get some
very interesting results,
and you start to really rethink
how you think of CDNs, not
just in terms of how many
nodes do you have, but really,
what's behind those nodes.
How are they actually
establishing connections,
how are they getting
their data, how
are they connecting
with ISPs, and so forth.
Let's switch to the slides.
One interesting thing is
also talking about anycast.
So I started using
GCP back in 2009.
I started with App Engine,
thank you very much.
I was actually a
customer at some point.
And that was all I knew.
Like, hey, this is how
it's supposed to work.
Why would you do
it any other way.
But anycast really
makes it super easy,
because you get
from where you are
to where you want to go
generally in a single hop
or very close to a single hop.
And you can compare
that to access
over a regional
external IP address.
And again, we saw
how simple it was.
We just create a
single DNS entry,
and all our traffic would
flow through that distributed
infrastructure.
So we'll take a look at
how anycast actually works.
And this is not necessarily
CDN, but it's actually
showing if you do a trace
route from let's say,
a VM on a standard network
in let's say, Frankfurt--
if you do the [? MTR ?]
on that load balancer IP,
you will hit that endpoint
in essentially, a single hop.
My content is in the states.
But it will still get served out
of this infrastructure, which
is the single hop away from
that user in Frankfurt.
If you look at
non-anycast transit, which
means the Frankfurt VM has to
leverage a standard network,
bounce around the
internet, and go to LA,
you will have a lot
of hops in the middle
before you actually get there.
And if you start to add up
the milliseconds and all
the extra transit time, it
really makes a difference.
And of course, it
was easy to set up.
So we saw that already.
The other thing that the CDN
does is automatic optimization.
So whether it's 1
byte or 5 terabytes,
we can handle objects
anywhere in that range.
And we will automatically
optimize whether we
should put in SSD or HDD.
So you don't really have
to say this URL map,
because it has videos,
please put that in HDD.
This has smaller images,
please put that in SSD.
We'll just sort of see
the content [INAUDIBLE]
headers, et cetera.
We'll figure all that
out, and it'll be done.
The content chunking is
also handled automatically.
So which means if we get
a byte range request,
we will translate that byte
range request into the chunk
requests that we need.
We will go get those chunks,
cache them appropriately,
see what we have already
from an internal manifest,
and then serve the correct
stitched together byte range
request.
So if your byte range
is spanning two chunks,
we will take care
of that implicitly.
Like, there's really no extra
configuration or manipulation
you have to do.
BRIAN ROGAN: So let's talk
a little bit about security.
For that, I'm going to
hand it over to Brian.
So let's talk about how we
think about security at Google.
First of all, we have always
believed that the internet
should be SSL.
And so we kind of
start everything
here with no cost SSL.
That shouldn't be a feature
you pay for, your site should
be secure.
That's the way the
internet should be.
We make it easy for you to make
new certs with Google Managed
Certs.
And everything's
encrypted from our GFEs,
from our front end, all
the way to your back end.
So you know that there's an end
to end encrypted experience.
We have for signed URLs, which
help you secure your content,
so that you can make
sure which requests
are allowed to be there.
You can generate your signed
URLs offline with custom keys
or with keys that we provide.
And we actually do that say,
in the case of live video
or in the case of chunked video,
in the manifest to every chunk
request.
And the signature is validated
right at the CDN edge.
So if there's a request
that shouldn't get through,
they'll get blocked
right where they started.
You can see what that looks
like in the context of Saurabh's
demo.
We've actually signed
every chunk right
in the manifest file.
And that's pretty easy to do.
We have kind of example
code linked to here.
And again, that that's all
going to be checked right
where it happened.
Let's Talk a little bit about
DDoS attacks and DDoS defense.
So we have a product
called Cloud Armor
that you can use
with CDN that helps
you to write more complex
rules, and to be able to block
DDoS attacks where they start.
But at the end of the
day, to even get that far,
you need to make sure that you
have an infrastructure that's
scaled up and ready to
handle the scale of attacks
that we see on the
internet today.
So step one of DDoS
prevention at Google
is to out scale
this attack, right?
And that's where making
sure that you write along
with a provider who
has enormous scale
is a really important
consideration.
And we have a great
quote here from Damian,
when the folks that looks
at DDoS at Google, basically
saying that absorbing
the largest attacks
actually requires
the bandwidth needed
to watch half a million YouTube
videos at the same time in HD.
And we don't see that
trend slowing at all.
If anything, we see
the scale of DDoS
attacks that Google
sort of hockey sticking,
and that's the thing
that we've been
planning for in our products
and in our infrastructure.
And this is just an
example of what that
looks like in your project.
So we ran an
experiment just to see,
can we sustain a
million [? RPS ?]
DDoS attack on an
example project
in a load balancer in GCLP.
And you can kind of see that
through the entire duration
of the attack,
everything kind of stays
running smooth and steady.
And then I think the other
thing that's worth talking about
is that because we have
this global network,
and because all of your cloud
IDs are going to be anycasted,
that actually makes it very
hard to concentrate a DDoS
attack on any particular element
of the Google infrastructure.
So the DDoS attack
will actually get
absorbed across our
entire appearing surface
all across the world, where
it'll be handled and dealt
with there.
And so again, I
think what that means
is that when you
come to Google, you
have an infrastructure
that's built
to write out some of
the biggest attacks
that we know about today.
I'll hand it back to Saurabh
to just talk about how
to put this all together.
SAURABH GUPTA: So
winning, right?
Making it work for you.
We give you ease of use,
all of Google distributed
infrastructure and
serving capability
delivered to a single checkbox.
It gives you the anycast
IP, the content services,
the monitoring and logging,
programmatic control.
Everything is done
to an API so you
can script out all
the work that we just
showed through user interface.
The scale of course,
is billions of users.
If you look at, again, the
next most utilized services,
they do not have the same
order of magnitude of scale
that we routinely work at.
And the critical thing here
is ramp without warm up.
So if you have content, if you
have any type of end streaming
system, and you do not know
what demand is going to be,
it's very hard to kind of get
the right provisioning upfront.
But with Cloud CDN,
you really don't have
to worry about that the scale.
We'll just be transparent
and automatic.
Again, footprint.
So it's not just how
many can be served,
but where all can we serve it.
And again, the most popular
sites all across the world.
Some of them, like
the Google ones,
they all leverage
this infrastructure,
and you get to ride the
same underlying stack.
And of course, the security.
So it's not any good if you
can't protect your content
and your infrastructure.
So you do get all the
investments that we make.
You just get that
out of the box.
So it's the
outscaling of attacks,
the anycast distribution,
and the free SSL.